you should listen to your own excuses to
yourself through the lens of how you
would hear them if your worst enemy or
your least favorite person was giving
them to you I am not sure where this is
going if my least favorite person told
me that she was too tired to go to the
gym or oh I don't I don't eat clean
that's a lot of work I would immediately
lose respect for them because I'm like
I'm lazy they're just lazy that's just
an excuse this great advice is literally
equating yourself with your worst enemy
with someone that you truly hate let
that sink in for a minute because no
amount of exercise no amount of clean
eating no improvements to your physical
body is going to change that
self-loathing but two do you really
think that the kind of like tough love
approach works because of course there
may be outliers for whom this appeals
but their research actually tells us
that shaming someone into Health
behaviors only makes it worse it drives
us away from those behaviors so I'm not
really sure who gave that amazing advice
but I would start looking for a new
Mentor stat